as Trump visits the UK another nasty
display by a media that's lost track of
simple journalism first some hack told
the president about an anti-trump rant
by duchess megan trump clearly and
obviously referring to the comments said
he didn't know she was nasty
to him the press portrayed it as Trump
calling her nasty sorry it's not the
same thing then the media erupts after
Trump calls the London Mayor a loser but
that was after the mayor called him a
bigot Trump also said the Mayor was as
dumb as de Blasio but half as tall
that's funny
in fact this whole thing's funny when
hysteria meets the hysterical because
times are good when front-page news
isn't war but a silly feud me I'd rather
have a volatile president presiding over
good times than a boring president
presiding over bad meanwhile Sky News
touts a balloon when your analysis is
reduced to a blow-up toy
maybe London's adults have finally left
the building but that's our media and
its European clones always wrong on the
big things it comes down to the media's
three favorite words we know best and
the three words that they will never say
that could save them we were wrong so
they protest Trump as a populism sweeps
their country it's something everyone
sees but them the rise of the brexit
party made possible by the media's
blanket smear of the average Brit has
now made that there Trump so the island
feels smaller a place where not just
Trump isn't welcomed but also John
Cleese Morrissey Johnny Rotten he'll
half the country and when Trump is gone
and they bathe in nostalgia for their
own days of hate all they'll have is
their stupid balloon so okay Danny
you've been to these things can we show
some of this vo what is that voice over
the banquet right so this is the banquet
that's going on okay I'm gonna die I'm
just gonna say that I don't think
there's anything that could be more
miserable than this no one there seems
to be having a good time
I think the Brits are really funny but
they know how to create a really bad
time like it's so quiet everybody's
serious
no one's smiling is this just miserable
for everybody well no I see what you
mean
yeah because you have to itself prim and
proper and you can't just hang out you
got to mind your P's and Q's and you
have to remember curtsy not curtsy shake
hand Oh check a hand put your hand with
all these things you cannot do right but
that is a beautiful setting and it's a
really good good symbolism for America
yes in the UK coming together and look
at that like that's gorgeous it is but
you do it even though it's gonna be
terrible one you know it fishing land
the two animals that smell the city card
is easy help by being insulted I think
it he does right it helps him you think
yeah yeah yes yeah oh maybe I well I
know it's like what is it two thirds of
Britons disapprove of trumps alright
he thinks possibly that it pumps up his
ratings yeah but here's where I disagree
with you I don't think the media told
Trump to lie and he's the one who said
that she was he didn't know she was
nasty yeah he was talking about him like
I didn't know she was nasty no I think
he said you know she was nasty after
that he was read the quote where she was
critical I'll see him that's what well
take well I think that what was amazing
to me is he then retweets yes the tape
yeah you can listen for yourself it's
not me and Greg and Dana disagreeing he
actually said no I didn't know but
that's why what I'm saying is yeah
because he knows he was saying I didn't
know she was nasty meaning like that
Dana said something nasty yeah but he
just called this woman there's I guess
not nice anyway that's the way okay as
usual in our polarized era but I must
say it's almost oh well Ian because he's
saying now don't believe the fake news
don't believe the fake media it's the
media's fault I didn't know the New York
Times the AP everybody was so powerful
we could make the president line I don't
know what do you think Emily what do you
this whole mess well first of all I
would love to go to one of those centers
that's let me dream we were just talking
about yes before the show there'd be
to get all dressed up to represent the
state in that way to go to some amazing
- with everyone in there that all the
heads of state although it would just be
a fascinating collection of people and
state representatives and like an
opulence and glamour but ok back to this
for a second that was my point about
mayor Kahn's op Edie you know it was
entitled why it's unwritten rule out the
red carpet for Donald Trump
why doesn't he then model the inclusion
and you know the alleged embracing of
everyone that he purports to represent
and say instead why I am meeting with
President Trump and then list in his
op-ed the specific policy things that he
wants to discuss with him and why he
wants to try to change his mind try to
persuade him how they can meet in the
middle
etc I think this was a failed
opportunity on his part and frankly a
hyper generalized I mean president why
would I meet with the mayor I could hear
the leader of the free world like the
the Mayor of London who cares yeah
that's true
I mean although I love London I live
there it's a beautiful beautiful city
Jesse I think you haven't made it till
they make a giant balloon of you I think
the hair would touch the Stars the media
portrays the presidents the same way no
matter who goes over there if it's a
Republican definitely ed George Bush for
Donald Trump it's this boring American
who's going over there and they don't
know how to use their silverware and
they have destroyed the special
relationship between Britain and America
and that you know the Queen is is really
unsettled by this thing but they she's
obligated to do it but then Barack Obama
goes over there and they roll out the
red carpet for this special man and the
special relationship has never been this
strong and they ignore the gaffes
because everybody at home Google this
Google Barack Obama toasts the Queen it
was one of the most humiliating gaffes
you'll ever see on television he gets up
there and he tries to toast the Queen of
England and he goes like this - Cheers
her and she doesn't even pick up her
glass because they're playing her anthem
and she's not allowed to do anything
except sit there and watch the meeting
it buried that they also
varied the gift that he gave the Queen
he gave the Queen an iPod Barack Obama
of all his famous speeches and that
would be like Donald Trump signing a
copy of art of the deal and giving it to
this he creates this great excitement
and buzz that go into the meeting by all
of these things that happen and all
these side deals with the Royals and all
that but Milani I think stole the damn
fault
beautiful outfit as she looked gorgeous
and there is obviously there's an
anti-trump crowd there in London but
it's like saying that New York City is
America London is not the UK and there
is a large groundswell of support this
bricks for President Trump and also they
wish that Teresa may have been a little
bit more like him in pushing back
against the EU and trying to get out of
the wrecks it is it breaks it really the
response to the media the way Trump was
a response to the media here yeah but
the politicians in the UK couldn't pull
it off yeah I think that it was even
more I think it's actually even worse
than that which is that the it was
supposed to be like an economic
arrangement and it turned into the EU
starting to make all of these rules to
try to that change wanting to change
okay guys do get nervous watching
American politicians try to play the
etiquette game yeah I mean you watch
them and they don't know what to do with
their glass and we had the wars really
sort my problem I don't think that what
you said pay why is he bothering to even
meet with them in where I should be meet
with the minute guys I'm mayor he's a
world leader but he's got to meet with
Theresa May who's having trouble with
brexit and what does he say about brexit
Oh Theresa May you should have done
better you should have done this you
should have done more like me well you
know that's our representative but she's
about my point is why would you meet
with the mayor I'm meeting with Theresa
May she is like the leader of yeah but
he's the one who's been undermining her
and I don't think that's polite by the
way Emily yeah after you put on that hat
I think you would look yeah
[Laughter]
yeah oh wait my invitation hey one last
question how does Peter feel about the
John Cleese stuff you see about John
Cleese guitar about Peter like you can
imagine how he feels he's like you
always get in trouble for speaking the
truth
yeah alright